Have you ever wondered how you deal with others?
For example, in North America if you are a man
Longer than 175.7 cm or taller than 161.8 cm
You or you are above the general average
If you weigh less than 88.3 kg as a man and 74.7 kg as a woman
You or you are below average
While humans worldwide weigh 62 kilos on average
If you read less than 12 books per year
You are below average
However, it is likely that readers who are nerds have increased this number.
Reading 4 books a year is the most common.
And if you read more than 300 words per minute
You are above average
Write more than 40 words per minute
You are also faster than the majority
If you have a bachelor's degree or higher
You are above average
But if she does not finish high school
You are a developed country
You are much less than average with only about 10% of those who have not finished it
If you are a man who can lift weights weighing more than 135 lbs,
You are stronger than many
If you are a woman you can go miles
In less than 7 to 10 minutes
You are faster than the others
If that makes you sleep more than 6.8 hours
That is more than the majority
If you drink less than 3 cups of coffee a day
You are below average
Still thirsty? Most people drink 3 to 4 glasses of water a day
Too much fluid makes you urinate a lot?
If you urinate less than 6 times a day you are below average
If you need more than once a day
This is higher than average, based on studies>
But that does not necessarily have to worry.
The natural person releases the gases about 14 times a day
This is about 500 to 1500 mm
do you have a family?
If you end up having more than two children in your life, in most of Europe and North America,
That is higher than the average rate
But if you have less than 6 children in Niger
You are below average
If you watch the TV for more than 5 hours and 4 minutes a day
This is more than the majority
This is the same time that average people spend on their portable devices
But if you are a teenager and spend less than 9 hours on networking sites daily
You are actually lower than the average teens
Ordinary people also touch their cell phones more than 2,000 times a day.
Do you think you are smarter than the average person or lead better?
Or you think you have better health or stronger memory or that you are a fuller friend than the average person
It turns out that the vast majority of people also think that they are better than the average person
It is a phenomenon called delusional supremacy
Is a cognitive bias whereby people overstate their own qualities and abilities.
A study showed
That 87% of university students
Rated their academic performance above the average
Interestingly, people with low intelligence tend to overstate their intelligence
While those with an above-average IQ tend to underestimate their abilities.
Men are more likely to exaggerate their IQ by 5 points
While women reduce their abilities.
Perhaps the most shocking is that in the cognitive test
Even those with the lowest scores think they are above average
Which shows a strong illusion
Researchers believe this because these are the worst in the test
They are also the worst in understanding the skills required to do well
This article won the Nobel Prize in 2000
According to Charles Bukowski:
"The problem of this world is that fools are always confident of themselves most confidently, but the wise are filled with doubts"